so now the Pakistan cricket team has
arrived in India ahead of the Cricket
World Cup long-running political
tensions between the two countries makes
these visits rare the last time the team
was in the country was seven years ago
the team was only recently issued visas
and a warm-up match in Hyderabad will be
played behind closed doors we're going
early to our Sports Anchor Peter's
demott who's here with me right now so
Peter why is it that it's taken Pakistan
so long to return to India well as you
pointed out there it's tension between
the two countries at a political level
so the way that Cricket works for our
viewers who are not familiar is that in
between World Cups countries play
bilateral series against one another
it's test matches t20s Odis for example
this December India will be touring
South Africa and they will play a series
of matches and the World Cups every two
years one time you have a 50 over then
you have a T20 and so on and so forth
the last time it was held in India was
2016 that was a T20 World Cup Pakistan
were there for that but because the two
don't play bilateral Series against each
other this is the first time in seven
years that Pakistan are in the country
for Cricket and Cricket a huge deal in
both countries and a bigger deal still
when they play against each other which
is going to happen during this world cup
that's right it's the biggest match in
Cricket in terms of TV viewers in terms
of numbers populations when we talk
about the ashes England and Australia
but the combined population of the two
countries you're looking at less than
100 million Pakistan by themselves have
got more than that in terms of
population just to give you an idea the
two teams will play each other at under
bud at the Narendra Modi Stadium it's
the biggest cricket ground in the world
Nick it takes 132
000 people that's extraordinary isn't it
I mean the security is always going to
be an issue anyway and it is as we were
just saying in the warm-up match indeed
there's a warm-up match coming up
against New Zealand in two days time
actually that one taking place in
Hyderabad at a considerably smaller
venue compared to the Narendra Modi
Stadium but that one will not have any
fans at all it's going to be played
behind closed doors the official reason
given is that the board of control for
Cricket in India have said that they've
been informed by the authorities in
Hyderabad that there are festivals and
other public Gatherings taking place on
the day and therefore they cannot
guarantee security for the players and
indeed if they were fans at the stadium
and for the teams themselves of course a
massive occasion all round oh absolutely
uh the Cricket World Cup only comes
around every four years and India last
hosted it in 2011 it was a great
occasion they were the host nation and
they won they were actually co-hosts
because Sri Lanka and Bangladesh also
hosted a few matches but the final was
played in India as it will again be the
case this time around but now India are
the hosts outright no matches being
played in any of the other neighboring
states Peter excellent thanks for that
thanks for making that all clear to us
my pleasure thanks very much
now